buongiorno
come molti di voi probabilmente già
sapranno è una disciplina sportiva che
nasce in città più precisamente nei
sobborghi di parigi intorno agli anni 80
i fondatori di questa disciplina
provengono da famiglie piuttosto modeste
da un ambiente multietnico erano spesso
i figli della prima generazione di
immigrati e da città come every liszt
esser shell queste città sono note come
ville nouvelle le ville nuvelle vengono
realizzate intorno agli anni sessanta
sono delle cittadine realizzate secondo
le direttive degli architetti e degli
urbanisti contemporanei per cercare di
trovare un equilibrio fra gli spazi i
trasporti la qualità del costruito del
verde urbano
se le mettiamo a confronto con delle
città nel periodo industriale quindi che
erano estremamente caotica e inquinate
sicuramente sono stati fatti degli
enormi passi in avanti sono più sicure
sono più vivibili più fa misura d'uomo
ma siamo sicuri che si è realmente così
attraverso i miei studi in urbanistica e
attraverso una visione privilegiata
della città in quanto praticante di
parkour posso dire che non è sempre così
una volta superate quelle necessità
primarie quindi l'igiene la privacy la
sicurezza
io sono andate sviluppando delle
necessità più complesse come per esempio
il concetto di libertà individuale
questo concetto non è sempre stato
compreso secondo me fino in fondo ne è
stato guidato nella giusta direzione
sappiamo che chi progetta una città lo
fa pensando al futuro cercando di
anticipare prevedere la necessità dei
cittadini che poi ritroveranno un
riscontro fisico architettonico a quelle
necessità
quindi adesso in quanto cittadini vi
chiedo di pensare per un momento alle
vostre vite
cosa fate quando uscite da casa perché
uscite da casa
cosa vi spinge a farlo il 90 per cento
delle volte probabilmente uscite per
andare a lavorare o semplicemente per
andare a comprare il pane o per fare
shopping
altre volte volete svagarvi andate a
prendervi una birra con i vostri amici
ok queste sono tutte attività
normalissime che tutti noi svolgiamo
quotidianamente
ma che cosa hanno in comune la
transazione ci sono tutte le attività
che prevedono un rapporto economico
quando aprite la porta di casa
le ritrovate di fronte una infinita di
opzioni ma tutte prevedono un rapporto
economico che sia di tipo diretto
immediato ma dove voglio arrivare con
questo discorso
uno studio che mi ha colpito molto di un
sociologo americano di nome kingson il
quale sostiene che la città
contemporanee sono realizzate proprio
fisicamente
secondo la logica ferrea del mercato
capitalistico cioè ogni strada ogni
piazza ogni area attrezzata di una città
mira alla produzione di un capitale
economico ogni spazio mi era questo
quindi alla fine noi siamo degli
individui perfettamente liberi ma di
fare determinate cose in un determinato
modo e in un determinato contesto
in tutto ciò il praticante di parkour è
visto come un sovversivo
non nel senso che è praticante quando va
in strada porta un attacco cosciente al
capitalismo all'architettura della città
ma perché sceglie da sé che cosa fare
come farlo ea prescindere dal contesto
si prende la responsabilità delle
proprie azioni e trova nuovi modi di
vivere l'ambiente urbano
quando un 36
mi ripeto questo comportamento non è un
cosciente atto sovversivo ma è una
conseguenza imprevista
ok quando un 36 così si chiamano i
praticanti di parkour porta la sua
pratica per le vie della città ne
ribalta
gli schemi né forze le regole quindi un
passamano non è più legato il suo
concetto di assistenza alla
deambulazione ma diventa un ostacolo
ossia un'opportunità di movimento e di
scoperta di se stessi due muretti non
diventano più un interferenza ma
diventano un opportunità di mettersi
alla prova ad esempio con un salto di
precisione
quindi il suo uscire da casa soddisfa un
bisogno che è nessun esercizio
commerciale può soddisfare il bisogno di
autodeterminarsi e di essere libero una
dimostrazione di ciò è che spesso gli
spot cioè i luoghi che si prestano alla
pratica del parkour si trovano in
periferia sono degli angoli di cemento
dimenticati inutilizzati e che non hanno
nessuna attrattiva specifica tuttavia
vengono vissuti dai dai tre serre
vengono in un certo senso riqualificati
vengono sottratti alle attività illecite
e poi dovremmo anche definire cos'è
un'attività lecita o non lecita
all'interno di una città o semplicemente
vengono sottratti al degrado
questi spot si trovano spesso in zone
che presentano dei salti di quota che
sono raccordati con muretti e ringhiere
scale terrapieni informazione degli
ambienti complessi e l'ambiente
complesso stimola la creatività di gioco
ed il gioco ed il divertimento sono
degli elementi fondamentali nello
sviluppo dell'essere umano in quanto
attraverso questi intraprendiamo delle
sfide sempre più complesse e attraverso
la conquista del fallimento di queste
sfide ne abbiamo un'enorme crescita
personale
la mia tesi di laurea trattava più o
meno questi stessi argomenti
ovviamente ponendo molta più attenzione
all'aspetto urbanistico di quanto non
stia facendo oggi purtroppo il mio
lavoro non fu particolarmente apprezzato
dalla commissione tant'è che è una mia
professoressa mi chiese durante l'esame
ma allora secondo lei
dovremo progettare delle città con
muretti ovunque con molte più barriere
architettoniche
io rimasi un attimo basito e dalla
domanda
e non mi sarei mai aspettato dalla mia
professoressa ma la risposta è
ovviamente no il parkour è una risposta
naturale a una mancanza da parte degli
urbanisti da una errata lettura dei
bisogni delle persone
il parkour non è la risposta al problema
metti in mezzo a ogni strada e la gente
sarà libera di esprimersi ma deve essere
visto come chiave di lettura di un
fenomeno sociale mette in luce il
bisogno delle persone di avere degli
spazi pubblici che siano gratuiti che
siano vivibili gli spazi in cui poter
semplicemente stare in cui poter passare
il tempo in cui potersi confrontare e un
punto di vista culturale un punto di
vista ideologico e perché no anche da un
punto di vista fisico
quello che mi immagino è un po il
concetto di una piazza 2.0 in cui si
mette in primo piano la figura della
persona ok e non dell'esercizio
commerciale o della proprietà privata
una piazza che non sia vuota con due
panchine che non sono utili a nessuno ma
che torni a essere un organo vitale
della città
un altro aspetto ma cui tengo molto e
che conseguenza imprevista della pratica
del parkour è la crescita personale e
psicologica di chi lo pratica
quando vedete un allenamento di parkour
e dell'esterno ho guardate i salti che
fanno i tre serre o guardate i loro
video su youtube possono sembrarvi delle
follie dei movimenti delle azioni
pericolosissime
premettendo che tutto ciò che facciamo
alle spalle anni di allenamento di
preparazione è che tutto avviene in
maniera estremamente graduale a volte
puoi anche essere vero nel senso che non
tutti sono assegnati
altre volte invece ciò che facciamo
soltanto potenzialmente rischioso
l'uscita della comfort zone cioè da
quell'ambito di movimenti con i quali
siamo perfettamente il nostro agio porta
nei praticanti o il praticante ad
evolvere ea conoscersi molto più
profondamente
d'altronde anche il bambino quando
impara a camminare
esce dalla propria zona di comfort a
beneficio della propria sicurezza e
dello sviluppo della propria personalità
quindi perché dovrebbero ad un certo
punto smettere di farlo il bagaglio di
conoscenza acquisito dal praticante lo
rende consapevole delle proprie capacità
dei propri limiti e questo è un effetto
molto potente sulla tranquillità sua
nella vita di tutti i giorni
il saper affrontare delle sfide
prendendosi il giusto tempo il saper
fallire sono delle virtù e molto
importanti a prescindere dalla pratica
del parkour uno studio molto
interessante è stato svolto in
inghilterra è che ho analizzato per la
stesura della mia tesi vedeva come
soprattutto in età scolare il risk
taking fosse un fattore non solo di
crescita personale dello studente ma
avesse anche un ruolo sociale e
aggregativo formidabile in alcune scuole
i ragazzi che facevano largo uso di
tecnologie e passano gli intervalli
connessi sui social network avevano poi
degli scarsi risultati accademici e
delle difficoltà relazionali nel mondo
reale si è visto come con l'introduzione
di attività all'aperto specialmente in
natura e del parkour durante le ore di
attività moto pari a questi ragazzi
abbiamo svoltato sia dal punto di vista
accademico che è dal punto di vista
relazionale
questo per dire che spesso nelle nostre
vite tendiamo ad escludere il rischio
pensando in questo modo di correre il
pericolo di farci male o di rimanere
delusi dagli altri ma peggio ancora da
noi stessi è invece non funziona così è
solo preparandosi adeguatamente
gradualmente situazioni anche
potenzialmente rischiose che potremo
fronteggiare poi più facilmente le sfide
che la vita ci pone inevitabilmente
davanti fuggire dalla realtà
restando seduti con un telefonino in
mano
quello invece secondo me è il vero
pericolo grazie dell'attenzione
[Applauso]